You say in the film, like, what am I gonna do,
almost, when I'm steady and good.
Like, will you know how to write?
Right.
When things are so stable?
(Olivia laughs)
And does life ever even get there? But-
You know, I definitely like to think
that it's gonna be even better than.
I think you have to be stable and feel full
in order to give so much of yourself to your art.
And so I think
if you're just like constantly depriving yourself
and you're constantly sad, then your art suffers in a way.
I agree.
Know what I mean?
And a lot of people get like into drugs,
and they do this and they're like-
Yeah. Ooh.
It's an excuse for art.
I've been there. I've tried that.
And I'm like, you know what? That's not sustainable.
It's definitely a weird thing to like write
about your personal life sometimes, but-
No, it's the only way-
I think so-
To do it.
And when you write, do you think about someone hearing it,
seeing it, listening to it, or do you write it just for you?
Never. I always write just from me.
(hands clapping)
I knew this. I knew this about you, I knew it.
I think the second you start thinking about
how something's gonna start being perceived,
it just loses all of its magic.
And I think it, I try to be as vulnerable
and honest as possible in my songs.
I think that's like one of the hallmarks
of good songwriting.
And I think when you're thinking about
how people are gonna perceive it,
it just makes it so hard to do that, it's anxiety inducing.
So yeah-
Such a relief to hear you say that.
Yeah.
I'm so inspired by you.
You have made the world a better place.
And in my heart of hearts, I wondered and secretly hoped
that you were having that insular experience,
because I think that's what makes it the most humble
and relatable and universal.
(audience applauds)
Oh, Olivia, thank you so much for your time.
I just love you so much.
Olivia Rodrigo, Driving Home 2 U,
premieres March 25th, only on Disney Plus,
I'm sure everyone will be watching.
(upbeat theme music)